pues esta breve charla se llama no
tengas miedo a equivocarte levante la
mano quien ha sentido miedo a cometer un
error honestamente levante la mano
perfecto gracias yo le estoy levantando
y nunca ha sentido miedo a equivocarse
levante la mano ninguno y si alguno la
levanto es un mentiroso porque uno de
los más grandes miedos que tenemos los
seres humanos no es tanto equivocarte o
equivocarnos son las consecuencias que
vienen por equivocarte algún amigo me
decía una vez que el miedo al hacer el
ridículo es tal vez el miedo más grande
que tienen los seres humanos un amigo
que es psicólogo que es experto en la
materia entonces yo me quedara
reflexiones dije o sea que en un funeral
la persona que le piden oye dedican unas
palabras al difunto ese preferiría estar
siendo el difunto que decir las palabras
para todos porque es así el miedo porque
nos entre el síndrome yo digo que es el
síndrome del isi y si me equivoco y si
hago el ridículo y si me veo como un
tonto y si me rechazan y si no sé de lo
que estoy hablando y si se da cuenta que
estoy nervioso es el síndrome famoso del
y si no entonces lo curioso en la vida
es que ese miedo a equivocarte para
empezar te desconecta de tu corazón
quien usted es dado cuenta que cuando
tienen miedo a cometer un error la
energía o si no lo ha notado la próxima
vez que les pase pongan la atención la
energía se va aquí a la cabeza empieza
una una tormenta aquí adentro y te
desconectas de aquí de tu corazón que es
de donde viene la creatividad viene la
verdad quien cree en dios quien creemos
en dios de dónde viene la inspiración la
fuerza del universo todo eso viene de
acá pero cuando tienes miedo a
equivocarte estás metido aquí quien ha
notado eso levante la mano quien ha
notado esa presencia y estoy pensando
tenemos esa vocecita en la mente no y si
me equivoco y si me pasa bueno ahora el
problema es que el miedo a equivocarte
es un miedo irracional verdad porque el
miedo no es nuestro enemigo siempre digo
que nuestra mente puede ser nuestra
mejor amiga o nuestra peor enemiga
depende si no se está respaldando para
llegar a manifestar nuestros sueños o si
la mente nos está diciendo cosas que nos
separan de la posibilidad de alcanzar
nuestros sueños y cuando la mente
empieza con los miedos irracionales que
son estos y si me equivoco y si la riego
y si me rechazan y si me veo como un
idiota y si no me vuelven a invitar y si
no digo lo adecuado esos son miedos
irracionales es decir es algo que no
está ocurriendo un miedo relacional es
muy útil porque es un miedo algo que
está ocurriendo si voy por la selva y me
sale un algún oso o una pantera me sale
la mascota aquí desde la universidad en
la vida real y me pela sus dientes y tos
y me dice mira esta casa le veo cara de
que trae hambre ese es un miedo racional
verdad o sea le estoy teniendo miedo
algo de verdad si voy por la calle y
alguien me apunta con una pistola pues
es un miedo racional es verdad pero
cuando es como cuando les ha pasado
alguno de ustedes que se suben a un
avión y empiezan las bolsas de aire
quien se ha subido un avión levanten la
mano
es más bien quien ha volado en un avión
se subieron a
ambos lados levante la mano quien no ha
volado
levante la mano quien no ha volado pero
siente que ha volado o se empieza a
mover el avión y empiezan las bolsas de
aire que son lo más normal del mundo las
sobrecargos siguen sirviendo la comida y
el agua lo que sea y empiezas tu bici me
mato y si se cae en picada y empiezas a
imaginarte tu muerte no a veces me ha
pasado a mí que empiezo a imaginar que
el avión va a caer y digo cuánto tardará
en caer cuando me iré a morir antes de
que caiga y si caigo y si y si me quedo
vivo y si me quedo con una discapacidad
que no dios mío que voy y empiezas a
sufrir por algo que no está ocurriendo
ese es el miedo irracional ese es el
miedo que no nos sirve de nada el otro
si no sirve entonces ese miedo a
equivocarme es un miedo irracional es
miedo algo que no está pasando pero de
dónde viene el bien de dónde viene ese
miedo a equivocarme me para ser más las
cosas bueno pues resulta que viene de la
escuela
de la universidad panamericana pero
viene en la escuela porque tenemos es
uno de los temas más importantes que
aprendí cuando conocí a robert kiyosaki
el autor de padre rico padre pobre si no
lo han leído se los recomiendo que lo
lean es un excelente libro y él y él
hablaba mucho de esos temas entonces
ahí fue donde me di cuenta que el
problema empieza en el sistema educativo
que tenemos el sistema educativo nos
enseña algo terrible terrible terrible
me refiero no a méxico sino a la el
sistema educativo a nivel mundial en las
escuelas desde que estás chiquito te
enseña a qué equivocarte está mal
y ese es un gravísimo problema te
enseñan porque te enseñan a qué
equivocarte está mal bueno porque el
sistema educativo fue creado para crear
lo que en ese tiempo en 1920 1930 o en
aquellos tiempos donde de ahí viene ese
sistema educativo que era lo que el
mundo necesitaba pues una eran soldados
porque había guerras por todo el mundo
no pasó la primera menos 30-40 pasó la
primera guerra mundial la segunda guerra
mundial los países estaban en guerra
todo el tiempo
entonces una de las cosas que el
gobierno necesitaba era tener soldados y
un soldado tiene que ser creativo
innovador tomar riesgos o qué tiene que
hacer un soldado
obedecer órdenes y no equivocarse es
calladito haz lo que te digo y no tiene
vayas a equivocar entonces el sistema
educativo fue diseñado para crear y no
me estoy burlando ni hablando mal de los
soldados es una profesión específica si
quiere ser soldado entonces el sistema
educativo que existe hoy no en la
universidad panamericana
educativo que existe hoy está creado
para eso y que otra cosa hacía falta en
esos tiempos había vea la época de la
revolución industrial no las máquinas y
cuando hay muchas máquinas que es lo que
necesitas en las grandes fábricas
obreros a latín hazte a la profesión muy
bien que es lo que tiene en común un
obrero y un soldado
que no se puede equivocar tiene que
callarse obedecer órdenes checar la
tarjetita hacer lo que le dicen sin
cuestionar órdenes entonces sorpresa es
así como que a de ahí viene tenemos un
sistema educativo tan viejo tan caducado
ya que une los autos han cambiado los
teléfonos bueno no existían y ahora
existen y siguen cambiando la televisión
ahora cambio ahora son teléfonos son
computadoras la tecnología cambia la
forma de construir un edificio cambia
los aviones cambian todo ha cambiado y
todo sigue cambiando pero el sistema
educativo tradicional sigue siendo el
mismo
cállate siéntate en tu mesa banco no
cuestiones no te equivoques si te
equivocas en el examen está reprobado es
nocivo y es miedo miedo miedo incluso
nos enseñan a timbrazos igual que en el
ejército saca una clase siempre empiezo
igual que en el ejército que las
fábricas estamos condicionados para
tener miedo el ejemplo más fuerte les
podría dar muchos ejemplos
todas las escuelas son así no todos los
maestros son así pero les puedo dar un
ejemplo del recuerdo más crudo que tengo
de mí de mi adolescencia estaba yo en
segundo de secundaria y la ciudad de
mexico en una de las mejores escuelas
públicas que había en un rollo para que
te admitirán ahí en la secundaria 4
moisés saenz entonces era como que un
privilegio que estuviera seguir super
militar el cabello cortito impecable la
ropa todo tenía que estar perfecto y me
acuerdo que estás acabando la clase de
deportes todavía no empezaba la clase de
historia pero la maestra de historia era
terrible se llamaba dulce y cuando la
conocimos nos dijo mi nombre es dulce
jóvenes pero me deberían haber puesto
amarga
mucho gusto bienvenida que qué buena
banda qué
y lo primero que así es alguien hablaba
algo de dos puntos menos cómodos en
cuanto tres días y bajaba puntos a lo
loco que hacía todo el salón
quietecito y me acuerdo que la maestra
dulce y yo le caía gordísimo y era el
peor alumno para la maestra dulce porque
yo nací en tijuana antonio era
fronterizo y yo traía yo hablaba más o
menos inglés yo traía mis ideas como
medio estadounidenses no tus niños de
frontera de tijuana y estaba en la
ciudad de méxico cuando en esos tiempos
el comunismo el socialismo ya ver que
existía el partido comunista de méxico y
la maestra era súper comunista y nos
decía ustedes se deberían levantar a las
4 de la mañana para trabajar en el campo
son unos flojos y no sé qué tanto y
hablaba mal de eeuu y bien de la unión
soviética ahora rusia y nos tenía todos
así y me pueden hacer a la maestra
entonces estaba acabando la clase de
educación física todavía no terminaba
estaba yo poniendo mis pantaloncitos
arriba de los shorts y todo y yo pues
para variar a mí me gustaba pararme en
frente del salón imitar a los maestros
imitar a los alumnos me los pedían a ver
hasta el de español así se va a ver
hacerle de matemáticas y entraba yo hoy
todo era paz ya yo estaba haciendo mil
100 mexicanos dijeron ahí desde desde
que estaba chiquito
y entré a la maestra y yo estaba
ya ven que me río un poquito fuerte
cuando me lleva
y no me pasó como el chavo del ocho' que
entró la maestra todo el salón se cayó
yo ja ja ja ja ja y de vuelta todo se
cae en la vuelta a ver y estaba 50 años
dice que se ríe
y si le gusta reírse le digo si repito
todavía no empezaba a su clase porque no
sonaba la chicharra dice le gusta raíces
y me gusta reírme sé muy bien en mi
clase no se viene a reír y todavía le
contesto yo soy una empieza su clase es
maestra
guau
desafía el comunismo como
misa si se quiere reír y que no ya no
quiero reírme
pues ahora se va a reír no tengo nada no
hay nada no está sucediendo en aba
chistoso y ríase yo no tengo ganas riese
o lo repruebo le reprobó el año y si era
capaz total para no ser largo el cuento
del cuento me hizo que me riera han
dicho que empezara a reír así como en la
novela se hace y todo el salón viéndose
como que estaban sacrificando al pobre
corderito en el altar no señor de aserrí
hace más rías y todo llegarle hasta que
la risa se transformó en lágrimas
obviamente empecé a llorar y me dijo muy
bien y sé ahora si se le quitaron las
ganas de reírse lejos y dice para que
nunca se vuelva a reír en mi clase y le
voy a decir algo la risa a buzz en la
boca a la risa abunda en la boca de los
tontos y usted se ríe no va a llegar en
ningún lugar
y
bueno pues me senté y bueno fui el mejor
alumno quietecito si arriba rusia a la
unión soviética sí maestra claro si el
comunismo bajo los yankees sí sí sí el
capitalismo en los negocios no va a lo
malo malo malo el campo vamos a trabajar
al campo que pase el año pero ese es un
y tengo otros ejemplos de otros maestros
que no eran así de una maestra de
geografía por el otro lado que era todo
lo contrario en la misma escuela ella
llegaba y nos daba el examen de
geografía yernos no nos decía jóvenes
aquí quieren que se aprendan todas las
capitales de europa y si la verdad es
que se lo van a aprender para pasar el
examen y después de su olvidar yo no
quiero eso yo les voy a platicar de la
vida del mundo de los que eran platicas
súper sabrosas y nos pasaba exponer y el
examen era con el libro abierto no sabe
el examen y nos decía todos todos están
aprobados lo único que quiero es que
respondan a estas preguntas y nos da
unos espacios enormes con su libro
abierto y explíqueme no copien del libro
expliquen lo que están entendiendo y lo
vamos a comentar
guau qué diferencia no ese no era el
sistema de ser una maestra rebelde que
si lo hubieran agarrado la hubieran
corrido de la escuela pero es una
diferencia muy grande el sistema
educativo tradicional te enseña como mi
maestra dulce amarga a que no te
equivoques y ahí está el problema a que
no te rías y hoy en día yo podría decir
la risa no está en la boca de los tontos
la risa está en la boca de la gente
inteligente la risa está en la boca de
la gente creativa la risa está en la
boca de los emprendedores la risa está
en la boca de la gente que se atreve a
cometer errores ya conectarse con su
corazón y aunque el mundo entero te está
diciendo que estás loco y que lo que
quieres lograr no se puede tú dices de
alguna forma de alguna manera yo por lo
menos lo voy a intentar y te conectas
con tu corazón y le sonríe a la vida y
lo intentas una y otra y otra y otra vez
y lo que fui descubriendo a través de mi
carrera es que lo que no nos enseñan en
la escuela es lo que más necesitamos
necesitamos pararnos del mesabanco
necesitamos aprender a hablar en público
necesitamos aprender a transformar un
noveno sí es decir a saber vender y no
me refiero a pedir dinero por un
producto sino otra vez aprender a
convencer a alguien aprender a repetir
aprender a escuchar aprender a manejar
tus emociones
aprender a crear equipos y cómo se hace
eso levantándote moviéndote cuestionando
te y sin tener absolutamente
ningún miedo a equivocarse porque en el
momento que tienes miedo equivocarte
entras en algo que se llama la parálisis
del análisis cómo le hago para no
equivocarme déjame juego todo en mi
mente y analizo todo y me aseguro de que
no me vaya a equivocar y así no se
aprende así no se crea un negocio así no
se crea una organización sin fines de
lucro así no se crea un mejor país es
del gobierno la iniciativa privada así
no vas a crear felicidad en tu vida la
única forma en que vas a crear felicidad
en tu vida es equivocándote si ustedes
no hubieran conocido a mí yo sé que
estoy bien grande ustedes también
chiquitos son puros bebés y que para
muchos es como chabelo porque crecieron
viéndome en la tele
la catafixia velocidad
si ustedes me hubieran conocido en
ciudad obregón sonora soy tijuana pero
empecé mi carrera y obregón porque mi
mamá estaba trabajando ahí yo estaba con
ella
1985 y yo tenía 15 años empecé a hacer
radio la boca me temblaban las manos me
temblaban no era capaz presentaba una
canción y ponía a otra me quito era
error tras error tras error te temblaba
de los nervios el gerente de la estación
de radio venía se asomaba a la cabina
demencia como vas terrible y sudaba yo
de los nervios ni sea tranquilo se va a
pasar tú síguele me equivocada y me
equivocaba y me equivocaba y me
equivocado si ustedes me hubieran oído a
los 15 años hubieran dicho este no hay
ni cómo ayudarle para que aprenda hablar
en público no puede y lo hice pero me
equivoqué y me equivoqué hasta que
aprendí festival acapulco 93 me dieron
mi primera oportunidad televisión y
visión son raúl velasco se enferma
rebeca de alba se queda font y acá me
dijeron que yo le había hecho eso a la
garganta de rebecca y es una gran
mentira pero me da mi primera
oportunidad salgo a conducir en vivo el
programa más importante en aquellos
tiempos cuando la gente veía y
todo el mundo veía la tele salgo y sacó
el micrófono del pedestal y me lo
estrelló en los dientes
de los nervios
me pegó así y los de la primera fila
y empiezo a hablar y me pegaba y yo este
codo mi técnica para no temblar porque
temblaba la mano de los nervios me
temblaba el micrófono me pegaba yo el
codo al cuerpo para que la presión fuera
ahí y soltaba la mano aquí y le hacía
así y me ponía como de ladito a la
cámara para que el hombre vieran
y la gente las primeras filas los oía
decían está temblando en acapulco era
cada puro acapulqueño no era algo que
haber muy educados que digamos y los de
la playa y todo era caleta ya sabes si
la onda está temblando el 9 del total
les voy a decir una cosa la única forma
en que se me quitó el temblor fue
haciéndolo y equivocándome y la única
causa por la que puedo dar hoy tengo el
honor de estar aquí con ustedes e
improvisar una conferencia es porque
llevo 35 años
equivocándome porque le perdí el miedo a
equivocarme porque aprendí y eso ha sido
si ustedes me preguntara marco antonio
cuál ha sido el más grande secreto que
nos puedes compartir para verla para
derecho tus sueños realidad en la
televisión es que aprendí a que cada
error que cometo lo convierto en un
chiste lo convierto en una broma lo
convierto en mi herramienta lo convierto
en mi trampolín para hacer algo mejor
así que no le tenemos miedo a
equivocaron el digo a los errores venga
bienvenido el error porque de ahí me voy
a agarrar para hacer algo mejor y de ahí
toma vida lo que hago soy yo simplemente
les quiero decir algo
si hay algo que quieren hacer con lo que
sueñan en su corazón lo quieren
manifestar en su vida si hay algo que
quieren hacer y todavía la mente les
dice no eres lo suficientemente bueno
amar nunca vas a ser tan grande que
nunca vas a hacer como que si la mente
te está haciendo pedazos porque todavía
no eres lo suficientemente bueno en eso
que amas significa que no estás
cometiendo el número de errores
suficientes significa que no lo estás
intentando equivocarte ya lo más rápido
posible para que aprendas porque de que
vas a aprender vas a aprender pero nunca
sentado analizando sino saliendo y
equivocándote una y otra vez una y otra
vez para que le digas al miedo gracias
miedo ahorita no me sirves los errores y
las equivocaciones son mis maestros y
gracias a ellos voy a mejorar y voy a
salir adelante muchas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]